PROFESSOR 1: --labs based
on electronic structure,
and this will cover the
next two computational labs.
And on Thursday,
we'll start looking
at some of the
finite temperature
ideas that are based
on the energy models
that we have seen.
This, by the way, is
[? Roberto ?] [? Bajo ?]
missing a penalty shot.
So a reminder of what we
have seen in the last class.
We have introduced the
idea of pseudopotentials.
In order to remove the cost of
carrying out calculation that
include the core electrons
that are very many, especially
in sort of larger atoms,
and that have exceedingly
high oscillations
around the nucleus
due to the orthogonality
constraint. what we have done
is we have substituted
what would be the z over r
Coulomb potential with--
inside of the core
region of the nucleus--
a pseudopotential.
That is a potential
that reproduces
the effect of the nucleus, and
of the frozen core electrons.
And as you can see,
this pseudopotential
tends to be repulsive close to
the origin, basically again,
reproducing this sort
of angular momentum push
outwards of the core electrons
to the valence electrons.
And in order to make this
pseudopotential very accurate,
there has been this idea
that has been developed
of norm conserving
pseudopotential that
will act differently on
the different components
of a valence electron
wave function.
So you have an
incoming electron,
so you have a sort of ground
state valence wave function.
You can decompose it.
You can decide how much of
it is SP or the component,
and you can act differently
on the different slices
of this wave function.
And so with this, basically,
we can solve a new problem
in an effective external
potential in which the lowest
energy ground
state will actually
be identical in energy
to the valence eigenstate
of the original so-called all
electron on the atom with all
its electrons.
And the wave function
for this pseudo-atom
will be identical to the wave
function of the real atom
outside of the core radius--
outside, in this case,
three atomic units
in this slide.
So this was sort of one of
the first important technical
proofs that were introduced
in the '70s and '80s
to make this calculation
really feasible.
The other sort of
idea that I want
to sort of remind
you is that whenever
we deal with extended systems--
solids, liquids,
and in particular,
when we have periodic
boundary condition-- that
is we have our unit
cell periodically
repeated in all dimensions-- the
eigenstates of our Hamiltonian
take the form of Bloch Theorem,
and get classified according
to two quantum numbers.
A discrete number-- the
bounding that's number n--
and the continuous number k.
And the overall
eigenstates can be written
as a product of two functions.
One is just a
plane wave that has
the periodicity of the so-called
crystal momentum K, one
of these quantum numbers.
And the other is the periodic
part of this Bloch orbital
written here as u.
And that this is a function
with the same periodicity
of your unit cell.
So overall, the orbital itself--
the [INAUDIBLE] orbital psi
can have any periodicity,
but it can always be
decomposed into a part
of a well-defined wavelength
times a periodic part.
Periodic part is
going to be smooth.
Again, we don't have
any more core electrons,
so close to the nuclei,
it will look just
as 1s, 2s, 2p orbitals.
And that periodic
part can actually
be expanded in a
set of plane waves--
plane waves that need to
satisfy the periodic boundary
condition of our system.
And so we have seen that
we can write the functions
e to the iGr, where the
G is a linear combination
of primitive reciprocal
lattice vectors with integer
coefficients, and
all those G vectors
are such that e to the iGr
has the same periodicity
of your direct lattice.
And these are the coefficient
of the series expansion.
And we sort of
can systematically
improve the quality of
this basic set expansion
by increasing the
number of G vectors
that we use, and we can
do that systematically
by taking G vectors with
longer and longer lengths,
or as we say, with higher
and higher energy cutoff,
because higher and
higher energy [INAUDIBLE]
longer and longer moduli for
the G vectors corresponds
to plane waves with finer
and finer periodicity,
so with finer and
finer resolution.
So this is a distinct
advantage of plane waves.
And in addition, this
basis sets do not
depend on atomic position.
So when we calculate
forces, say,
to do molecular dynamics
or a structural relaxation
calculation, we don't
need to take into account
the fact that the
basis set changes
with the position of the atoms.
Plane waves are not
the only choices.
There are a number
of other choices
that are very successful.
In particular, a lot of
the quantum chemistry
could use a Gaussian basis sets.
So atom-centered orbitals
that decay as Gaussians.
This is very convenient to do
calculations like the exchange
term in Hartree-Fock.
But of course, you could
have just a finite difference
representation.
So you could represent
your orbitals
on a grid of points
in real space.
That tends to be very efficient
to do parallel calculation,
but it's very difficult
to do accurate calculation
of the second derivative.
If you remember, when you expand
a function in plane waves,
you have an analytic expression
for the second derivative
just because the first and
second derivative of plane
waves are just ig or minus g
squared times the plane wave
itself.
And that's very important.
So that's when sort of
real space representation
becomes a little bit trickier.
And then there are
a number of sort
of more approximate
approaches based
on a number of sort of
atomic-like localized orbitals.
Or there are a number of
sort of accurate approaches
that are based usually on a
combination of a basic set that
has a plane wave-like
characteristic in the regions
that are far away
from the nuclei,
and then it has atomic like
characteristics in the region
inside the nuclei.
And this tends to be the most
accurate, but also slightly
more expensive approaches.
This concludes one of
the technical points
that you need to be careful
in a practical calculation.
The other point that sort
of comes over and over
again has to do with
Brillouin Zone integration.
Let me give you a first
example of a molecule.
So if you are calculating
the electronic structure
of a molecule, in the
course of your calculation,
you'll need to calculate
integrated quantity
like the charge density.
The charge density
of a molecule is
going to be the sum of
the square moduli of all
the single particle orbitals.
So if you are sort of studying
a molecule like just hydrogen 2,
well, you just take the
sum of the square moduli
of the first orbital--
you have more orbital,
more complex molecule.
You need to sum over
all the orbitals up
to the [INAUDIBLE]---- the highest
occupied molecular orbital.
You do a calculation
in a solid, you
have to do exactly
the same thing.
That is, you need to calculate
the charge density by summing
over the occupied states.
Now as I said, what
are the quantum numbers
that describe a solid
are a [INAUDIBLE]
and a continuous
index scale that we
call the quasi-momentum.
And we usually represent,
say, the energy of the states
in a solid with a band diagram.
And I've plotted here
on the left the band
diagram for silicon.
In particular, what
we are looking here
is in the Brillouin
Zone of silicon
along certain high
symmetry direction.
I presume these are the
high symmetry points,
like gamma would be 0, 0, 0.
[? Alpha ?] would
be 1/2, 1/2, 1/2.
Hope this is correct.
This should be x,
and it is 1, 0, 0.
So we plot the energies of all
the occupied bands of silicon
in different directions
along the Brillouin Zone.
Silicon has two
atoms per unit cell.
Each atom has four
valence electrons,
so we have eight valence
electrons per unit cell.
It's a system in which there
is basically spin degeneracy.
So there is really sort
of the same spatial part
for spin up and spin down.
So what we usually say is
that we can accommodate
two electrons for
each space orbital,
and they will just have
different spin quantum number.
So with these eight
valence electrons,
we end up with four valence.
And sometimes, because of
symmetry, you have degeneracy,
but you see that
somewhere like here
at a sort of arbitrary low
symmetry point in the Brillouin
Zone, you can clearly
see four bands.
So if we want to calculate the
charge density of the system,
we need to sum over all the
possible occupied states.
That is, we need to sum
over all the four bands,
and that's trivial.
But we also need to integrate
over all the possible k
vectors.
That is, we need to make an
integral in the Brillouin Zone.
That is, we need
to sort of really
sum over all these
possible states.
An integral is obviously
an analytical operation.
In practice, on a computer,
what we do is just
we discretize that
integral, and we take a sum.
So it means that--
and again, I'll use two
dimension as an example.
It means that if this
were my Brillouin Zone--
two-dimensional Brillouin
Zone, and my k vector
can be anywhere in
this Brillouin Zone,
what I would need to do
is an integral overall
the possibilities inside there.
But in practice,
what I'll do, I'll
just take a discretization.
And I'll calculate
my band structure
at each one of these points,
and say a regular aqueous space
dimension of k points.
And that's an
expensive operation.
So each calculation
at each k point
will require a self-consistent
diagonalization
of your problem.
And so really, the cost
of your calculation
is linearly scaling in
the number of k points.
So in reality, you want to use
as few k points as possible.
For a system like a
semiconductor or an insulator,
in which if you want--
the band gap structure
is very smooth--
it becomes fairly easy to
integrate that smooth bands
with very coarse measures.
So for something like silicon,
you might be already very happy
when you start to sample the
three-dimensional Brillouin
Zone with a uniform mesh of k
points that could have four k
points in each direction--
4 by 4, by 4, 6 by 6,
by 6, 8 by 8, by 8.
And this is sort of the order
of magnitude of the k points
that you need to use.
If you were to study for a
moment unit cell of silicon,
you might want to study,
say, vacancy information
energy like you were doing in
your first computational lab.
Then you are not going
to use two atom units.
You are going to use
a larger unit cell.
And without sort of
dwelling that much on it,
suppose that, again,
in two dimensions,
you double the size
of your unit cell.
What's really happening is that
the reciprocal lattice vectors
will become one half in length.
So remember this
general concept.
When you sort of increase
the size of the unit cell,
the reciprocal cell
becomes smaller.
Suppose that we have doubled--
we have gone from
two atoms in each--
two atoms in our unit cell to--
well, if we are
in two dimensions,
eight atoms in the unit cell.
We have doubled in real
space-- in reciprocal space.
Our Brillouin Zone
becomes 4 times smaller.
And so if we want to keep the
same quality of integration,
actually, it means that our
k point sampling needs only
to be one fourth the number
of points that we had before.
That is we still
use the blue points
that are included in this sort
of smaller blackish unit cell.
So that also means that, say,
if 64 k points is a good number
for a regular set of unit
cell of two atoms of silicon,
if now you are
going to use a, say,
unit cell that has
maybe 128 atoms--
much larger to calculate the
vacancy formation energy--
you really need only one k point
to calculate your total energy
with the same accuracy.
So there is this general
idea of scaling and folding.
You make your real space
calculation larger.
You actually need to
use fewer k points.
And if you are familiar with
sort of some of the solid state
ideas, that also
just means that when
you double the size
of your unit cell,
you are really refolding
some of this band
structure in a smaller space.
So you actually sum over a
number of bands that increases.
The situation is
slightly more complex
for something like a metal.
The sort of
fundamental difference
when you deal with
a metal as opposed
to a semiconductor
or an insulator
is that there is something
called a Fermi energy.
That is now there
isn't any more a gap,
so the total charge
density is again
given by sum of the states,
sum over all the bands,
and integral over
all the k space.
But really, the total
charge density--
so the ultimate
integral that would
be the number of
electrons depends really
on where we stop.
And there isn't any more
sort of natural separation
between empty and
occupied states.
So there is going to be
in a metal an energy level
that determines what is
occupied and what is empty,
and that's the Fermi energy.
So for copper I think has
11 electrons per unit cell
sort of FCC metal
with one atom per--
one atom in each unit cell.
What we really need to do
in our electrons calculation
is find what is
this energy level.
That is find what is
this Fermi energy, such
that the integral over all
the state below that level
gives us the right charge
density-- in particular,
the right number of electrons.
And this is sort of one of
the difficulties that come out
in metals, because now
what we are trying to do
is we are trying to integrate
the bands below a level--
below the black line.
And so you really introduce a
discontinuity in your integral.
And so to calculate
integrals of discontinuous
function usually requires
a much finer accuracy
in your k point sampling.
And so the calculation tends
to become much more expensive.
Nothing else.
So the general solution to this
problem besides using a larger
number of k points,
and particular accuracy
to this sampling issue is that
of introducing what is called
a finite electron temperature.
So what is actually done in sort
of every practical calculation
is introduce a small
amount of temperature
so that in reality, there's
a sharp discontinuity become
smoother.
Because when you have
an electron temperature,
states above the Fermi energy
can be slightly occupied
with the Fermi [INAUDIBLE]
occupation, and states
just below the Fermi energy
can be slightly empty.
So to summarize, I
mean, we need to be
careful in sort of sampling.
And that's the other sort
of fundamental parameter
of your calculation.
If you are dealing
with a metal, you
need to be particularly
careful, and you
need to use electron
temperature techniques.
If you are using sort of-- if
you are studying an insulator
a semiconductor,
what you usually do
is just use a regular
equi-spaced mesh of k points.
And that sort of
known in the community
with a technical name.
They are called [INAUDIBLE]
for some very good reason.
Actually, there
are some actually
fairly beautiful
symmetry thoughts
on why equi-spaced coarse
mesh can work very well.
But in practice,
it's nothing else
than choosing the blue points
inside of the green Brillouin
zone.
If you are studying a
really large system,
you can actually reduce
yourself to sampling only one
point in the Brillouin Zone.
Brillouin Zone has
become so small
that just taking sort of--
how do you call it?
A mean-- the
theorem of the mean.
That is, you can
substitute the integral
with the value of the
function at one point.
And usually, you
have two choices.
You can just use
the gamma point.
This means that 0, 0, 0--
that has a
computational advantage.
When you sample things
at the gamma point,
you can choose your functions
to be real instead of complex.
And so you have right away
your computational cost.
Or you can choose sort of what
could be the best single point
for your given symmetry
that's sometimes
called the Baldereschi point.
And that can be
again sort of useful
if you need to do an accurate
calculation in a large scale
system.
Once you have set these
two fundamental parameters,
you are really
ready to do actually
a practical calculation.
And so as I said, we have a
self-consistent Hamiltonian,
and so what you
need to do is you
need to iterate your problem
until the eigenstates
that you find give you
a charge density that
is identical to
the charge density
that you have done before.
So in practice, how would your
electronic structure code work?
Well, first you would tell
your code where the atoms are.
So you need to specify
the position of the atom.
Suppose that you are studying
silicon, you could sort of--
since you know actually what
is the structure of silicon,
you could already put
them in the origin,
and in the position one
fourth, one fourth, one fourth.
And then you need to
specify in particular
which flavor of
non-local pseudopotential
you are going to use.
That is, there will be a
library of pseudopotential
that basically represents a
silicon atom with all the core
electrons frozen.
And there are sort of a number
of technicalities that you'll
see in the lab on which
one you should choose,
but they are sort of more or
less all the same, at least
from this point of view.
Once the code knows
where the atoms are--
that is, knows the position of
the atoms inside the unit cell,
knows what is the
shape of the unit cell,
and what is the length
of the dotted lattice
vectors, this infinite
array of atoms,
the infinite crystalline,
or amorphous,
or disordered extended
system is set.
And what we really need to do is
throw the electron [? seeds ?]
and let the electron find
their own ground state.
And so we need to make sure
that we have the right basis set
cutoff.
That is, we are
going to describe
the orbitals [? anchored. ?]
We have the right sampling.
And at this point,
we can sort of
start the self-consistent
procedure.
And in the sort
of simplest form,
well, we first need
to figure out what
is our Hamiltonian operator.
The Hamiltonian, remember,
depends on the charge density
itself, because some of the
terms in the Hamiltonian,
like the Hartree energy,
the Hartree potential
of the exchange
correlation potential
depends on the density.
So we need to pick an initial
guess for a trial charge
density.
It could just be a superposition
of atomic charge density.
Once we have the
charge density, we
can construct the Hamiltonian,
the [INAUDIBLE] Hamiltonian.
The kinetic energy operator is--
we always know it.
But we can construct
this Hartree and exchange
correlation terms that
depend on the charge density,
and then we'll have
the external potential
that is given by this array
of non-local pseudopotential.
At this point, we
have the Hamiltonian,
and we try to find
the lowest energy
eigenstates for Hamiltonian.
In particular, we just need to
calculate a number of states
that is equal to the
number of occupied orbitals
if we are dealing
with a semiconductor,
or it's equal to the
number of sort of electrons
plus 20%, 30% in a
metal to make sure
that at different points
in the Brillouin Zone,
we calculate all
the bends that could
be below our Fermi energy.
So we solve this.
And this is really
the expensive step--
and I mean very expensive step
in any electronic structure
calculation.
And there are sort
of a number of ways
of diagonalizing a
matrix, of solving
this eigenstate equation.
In a basic set, it
tends to be very large.
When you do sort of a realistic
calculation, even for silicon,
you could have hundreds
of plane waves, So.
Hundreds of basic set elements.
And large scale calculation
like you would doing in research
would contain tens of
thousands of plane waves.
And actually, you don't--
you can't really diagonalize
on a regular computer
even a matrix that
has [INAUDIBLE]..
If you think a matrix that
has a dimension of 1,000
requires one million elements.
And one number-- a complex
number requires 16 bytes.
So just a matrix that
has 1,000 sides that
will require 16 megabytes to
be described, and this number
explodes quadratically
very quickly.
So you can construct
the full Hamiltonian,
and you don't want
to calculate--
if you have a matrix
of dimension 1,000,
it will have 1,000 eigenstates.
But you only care, say, if
you are studying silicon,
on the lowest four eigenstates.
So you want to have
numerical techniques that
calculate for you only the
lowest energy eigenstates.
And there are a number of them
that are well-established.
So now you have obtained
with one of these techniques
your lowest energy eigenstates,
and you sum their square moduli
to obtain the new
charge density.
And with this, you
go back to the step.
You construct the
Hamiltonian operator again,
you diagonalize new
density, and iterate.
Of course, naturally,
a recipe like this
would most likely
never converge.
So one needs to develop
a mixing approach--
mixing approaches that sort
make the change in the charge
density at every
iterative step smoother
than what I've described.
So if you calculate
a new charge density
and you diagonalize it again,
your second new charge density
will be even more
different from anything
that you have obtained before.
So what you really
do is you need
to find some schemes to
evolve in a very smooth way
your charge density.
So maybe once you
have calculated
the new sum of
eigenstates, you don't
take that as huge as
density, but you just
update your old charge
density with 10%
of what you have calculated now
to try to make the iteration
to self-consistent very smooth.
And I have to say a
lot of the know-how
in electronic
structure calculation
in the '90s has really
gone into trying
to find sort of mixing
approaches that evolve
our charge density
to solve consistency,
and that converge under a
large variety of circumstances
for large or complex systems,
especially for metals.
So stripped to
the bare elements,
an electronic structure code
really needs to do two things.
It needs to diagonalize
inexpensively
a Hamiltonian that expressed
on a plane wave basis
is a very large order.
And I just mentioned
the names of some
of the [? algorithm. ?]
Things like the [INAUDIBLE],,
and the [INAUDIBLE],, or some
of the conjugate gradient
algorithms are all
algorithms that
give us reasonable cost the
lowest energy eigenstates
of that Hamiltonian.
And then once you
have that eigenstates,
you need to calculate
charge density,
and you need to have
a mixing strategy.
You need to have a strategy
to evolve your charge density
towards self-consistency.
And that is also a
very tricky approach.
There is a sort of
completely different approach
to the problem that sees the
ground state solution not
as a self-consistent
iteration, but
as a nonlinear direct
minimization of the functional.
If you remember, we have
the energy function--
or I think it's written
here in the next slide.
No, it's not.
We have sort of written the
density functional of theory
energy functional, and it
is a well-defined expression
of the orbitals only.
It will be in one of the--
so the following slides
will pick it up again.
And so we can also
see the problem
as the problem of minimization
of that functional in a space
that is very large, because
the sort of variables that we
really deal with are the
coefficients of our plane wave
expansion.
But in principle-- and I'll
show you that in a moment--
we can actually write out
a minimization algorithm.
The advantage of this approach,
if it's done properly,
it has always a solution.
If you keep minimizing
your energy, at the end,
you will get to a global
or to a local minimum.
So this approach tends
to sort of converge
under every circumstances
if done properly, and done
properly is not trivial.
But then sort of the efficiency
of the different things
is really system dependent.
And I guess without wanting to
bore you with sort of math--
so just I wanted
to remind you again
what happens in our computer.
That is what happens when
we say we want to solve
this eigenstate equation.
Supposing let's say we are in a
self-consistent diagonalization
approach.
And as always, you have to
remember we expand our wave
function in a well-defined
set of orbitals--
that is our basis set.
I represented here them as phi.
And it could be plane waves,
it could be atomic orbitals.
We use plane waves all the time.
So really, in our
computer, our unknowns
are these coefficients of
this basis set expansion.
And so our eigenstate equation,
once we multiply on the left
by phi and star, and integrate,
is really a matrix problem.
So I've written it here as
just the same eigenfunction
equation written over there.
And if we call hmn at the matrix
element of the Hamiltonian
between, say, two plane waves
of different wavelengths,
this is what our problem means.
It's just a linear
algebra problem.
We need to find the
eigenvalues for which there
is a possible solution,
and the possible solution
will be eigenstates.
And an eigenstate
is nothing else
than an appropriate
set of coefficients
that satisfy this equation,
and those coefficients put back
in here will give
us actually what
are the full eigenstates
of our problem.
So this was the sort
of self-consistent
diagonalization.
As I just said a
moment ago, we can also
look at the problem as a
nonlinear minimization problem.
Once we have decided on an
approximation for our exchange
correlation functional, could be
a local density approximation,
could be a generalized
gradient approximation.
This is a well-defined
quantity in which,
again, the external
potential is given
by this array of
non-local pseudopotential.
And the Hartree energy is just
the functional of the charge
density.
And the charge
density itself is thus
the sum of the square
modulus of the orbitals.
So in reality, this energy
is a function of that psi,
or in other terms, is nothing
else than a very complex
function of those c1
to cn coefficients
of each eigenvector.
So this is nothing else than
a minimization problem, again,
on a number of variables
that can be 1,000 if you are
studying two atoms of silicon.
And it can be in the tens
of hundreds of thousands
if you start to do really
serious calculations.
So again, it's a
fairly complex problem.
A huge number of variables
that you need to deal with,
and a nonlinear
expression for the energy.
But again, in principle, if we
have this explicit expression
for the energy, E of psi,
where the psi that we consider
around only the occupied
orbitals, what we can do
is nothing else than take
the functional derivative
with respect to that psi.
I'll consider them
real here just
to avoid sort of complex
conjugate numbers.
And at the end,
this is nothing else
than calculates the derivative
of the energy with respect
to all the coefficients,
say, for i that goes 1 up
to the cutoff, all the
coefficients of all
the occupied orbitals.
So you see, the larger
your system becomes,
the more basis elements
you'll need to use.
I mean, if you double
the size of your system,
if you look at the
math, you'll actually
need the twice the
number of plane waves,
as it makes sense,
to describe a charge
density or a wave function
with the same resolution.
So you double the
size of your system.
The number of plane waves to
describe a single particle
orbital becomes twice
as large, but now you
will also have twice as
many occupied orbitals.
So just the number
of this coefficient
has become four times as large.
So again, this calculation
becomes very expensive
very quickly.
But again, this is well-defined.
I mean, we can just
actually write explicitly
the nonlinear function
of the previous slide
in terms of the coefficients
of the plane waves.
This is actually done in
one of the article posted.
There is a review of modern
physics by Mike Payne
and coworkers-- among others,
John [? Gianopulos ?] at MIT.
And they actually
work out the algebra
of all these derivatives.
And then once you
have the derivatives,
you have the
gradients, and you know
how to move along and go
to the minimum following
the gradients.
The only difference with a sort
of regular minimization problem
is that this is a
constraint problem.
That is what we have because
these are really electrons,
and not just sort of
arbitrary functions.
The electrons need to be
meaningful quantum states,
so they need to be orthonormal.
So this derivatives
with respect to the c
need actually to take
place on the hyper surface
where these conditions
are satisfied.
That is, if you were to evolve
the coefficients of the plane
waves, what you would
find is that as soon
as you have sort of changed
them by a little amount,
your orbitals per
se are not going
to be orthonormal anymore.
So this constraint is
sort of fundamental,
and this is what
ultimately limits sort of--
or determines the computational
costs of our calculation.
Because again, if we double
the size of the system,
we'll have twice as
many plane waves,
and we'll have twice as
many occupied orbitals.
So we have already
a cost of fours.
But those occupied
orbitals will need
to be orthogonal to each other.
And so the number of
these matrix elements
that you need to calculate
has become also twice--
or the number of
orbitals in this matrix
have become twice, so the
number of matrix elements
has become four times as large.
You see, we double the
size of the system,
we'll have twice as
many orbitals here,
twice as many orbitals here.
And this integral is
going to take place
on a region in space
that's twice as large.
So 2 by 2, by 2 gives
us a factor of 8,
and so gives us the,
ultimately, cubic scaling
of cost of density
functional calculation.
You go from two atoms of silicon
to four atoms of silicon,
your calculation has become
eight times more expensive.
Hartree-Fock in its
original formulation scales
as the fourth power.
Other quantum chemistry approach
scales as the fifth, sixth,
or seventh power.
So it becomes very easy
to sort of reach, really,
the limit of
calculation that you
can do on a regular
computer or even
on a regular supercomputer.
And there is a lot of effort
to develop what are called
linear scaling approaches.
That these electronic structure
algorithm that scale linearly
as the size of the system.
And somehow, they are
all based on the idea
that sort of physics or
quantum mechanics is local.
So if your orbital at
the end is ultimately
localized in a certain
region of space,
it will be automatically
orthogonal to orbitals
that are very far away.
Because if this is
localized somewhere here,
and this psi i is
localized somewhere there,
their overlap will
be 0 by definition,
and so we don't need to
worry about orthogonality.
So somehow, locality
of physics, locality
of quantum mechanics
in principle
tells us that there are
linear scaling approaches that
could work, although,
none of them
have really made into sort of
production electronic structure
at this stage, although there
is a lot of ongoing effort
in many groups.
So with this [INAUDIBLE]
we conclude also
all the technicalities.
And what we'll do in
the rest of the class
will give you a sort
of panorama of what
typical applications of density
function of theory calculation
are going to do.
And I'll go very
quickly over this.
I have here sort
of cases in which
we could be interested in
structural excitations.
So when you start warming up a
system, a molecule, or a solid,
you start exciting the different
normal modes of your molecule
or of a solid.
I've shown you some of the
possibilities for something
like a carbon nanotube,
because that band--
we have a banding mode up there.
We have a pinching mode, and
we have a breathing mode.
And so these are all
the possible structural
excitations, and
you can actually
calculate this structural
excitations using
density functional theory.
And I've given here a comparison
between the case of diamond--
what is calculated with the
sort of state of the art
[INAUDIBLE] code
like you are going
to see in your
laboratory, and what
is measured actually
with the neutron
scattering, the red dots.
So you see without really
any input parameters.
And once you have really
phonon dispersion,
you can calculate all the
thermodynamics of solids.
That is really basically
based on the statistics
of excitation of this
vibrational degrees of freedom.
So you could calculate, say,
how your elastic constant
for your bulk models
changes with temperature,
and this is the
calculated black line,
and you could compare
it with experiments.
Or you could take
one of your slabs
like you have seen in the first
laboratory in which you were
calculating the surface
energy, and you could actually
put it in motion.
You could follow at a
given time temperature
the dynamics of the atoms.
And you want to have
a slab thick enough
so the atoms in the middle
really act as bulk atoms.
They don't see the
presence of the surface,
and then it becomes very
easy to investigate what's
happening on the surface.
And so you can have sort
of a snapshot of sort
of how the atoms are moving
on the outer layers, what
are the sort of
typical displacements
of typical mean
square displacements.
Or you can say study how the
distance between the layers
evolved with temperature.
So you can look at, say,
how, as you increase
the temperature of
your slab, the distance
between the surface layer
and the second layer
changes with temperature.
And this would be
the computation,
and here we have the
experimental value.
And there are sort of lots
of interesting physics
that takes place,
again, if you look
at the distance between
the second and third layer,
if the red line above and
the system expands there.
And sort of with
computation, you can actually
probe your system deeper and
deeper, where experiment starts
to become very difficult.
It's almost impossible
to look at what the fourth
layer in a surface does,
and what the fifth
layer of a surface does.
I think in order to keep
the balance of the lecture,
I'll actually switch on to
Professor [? Sidor's ?] part
so he can show you some
of the other application.
And if we have time either
in one of the next classes,
I'll show you some of
the other applications
that we have mentioned.
So I think I'll pass over
the lecture to Professor
[? Sidor. ?]
PROFESSOR 2: So Professor
[? Mazari ?] already gave you
some generic applications.
What I want to do for
the rest of the class
is actually give
you some numbers,
and really look seriously at
what the typical accuracies are
that you can expect
from what we'll
call density functional theory,
but what we mean with that
is sort of standard
density function theory
as we kind of explain
it to you in the class
in the local density
or generalized gradient
approximation.
So these are sort of staples
of electronic structure methods
now.
But that doesn't mean that
there are, in some cases, not
already better forms out
there, but they're often
very much in the research stage,
and there wouldn't be things
that you would either
easily do on real problems.
You wouldn't get
your hands on them,
and you wouldn't necessarily
easily learn from them.
So again, what we're
going to talk about
is the kind of standard staple
of electronic structure.
Before I did that, I want to
say a little bit about a topic
we haven't touched
about, which is
what's called the spin
polarized version of density
functional theory.
If you remember, the
Hohenberg-Kohn theorem,
everything is, in
essence, expressed
in terms of the charge density.
Everything is a function
of the charge density.
And the electron spin never
explicitly appears in there.
But of course,
electrons have spin.
If you don't consider any
coupling with the angular
momentum, it's really
just up or down
spin, so plus or minus
a half [INAUDIBLE]..
And we'll treat
here, in the lecture,
spin as a scalar quantity.
So really, spin is
just up or down--
plus 1 or minus 1, or
plus a 1/2, or minus a 1/2
in the appropriate units.
And in reality,
spin, as soon as it
applies to the angular momentum,
becomes a vector quantity.
Also as soon as it couples
to a magnetic field
from the environment, it
becomes a vector quantity.
And people do that
now already, treating
spin as a vector quantity, but
most codes that you will use,
spin will simply be
treated as a scalar, which
is fine for most purposes.
We tend to refer to them
as just up and down spin.
I'll often write that with
the either up and down arrow.
Now why do you actually need
to treat the electron spin?
Let me just sort of give
you a refresher of why
you need to deal with the spin.
Well, the reason is the Pauli
Exclusion Principle really.
Is that the Pauli Exclusion
Principle tells you that two
electrons cannot be in exactly
the same quantum state.
Remember that?
So that means that if you have
two up electrons approaching
each other, versus say an
up and a down electron,
these will approach
each other differently.
Because these two are
in the same spin state,
so if you bring them
very close together,
they essentially now get
the same coordinate as well.
So they almost have the
same quantum numbers now,
and the Pauli exclusion
principle prevents that.
So the Pauli Exclusion
Principle keeps electrons
with parallel spin essentially
away from each other.
Whereas if you have electrons
with empty parallel spin,
even if these are at
the same position,
they don't have the
same spin, so they
don't have the same
set of quantum numbers,
so the Pauli Exclusion
Principle doesn't act on them.
And the Pauli
Exclusion Principle
is essentially something
that keeps the electrons away
without an explicit term
for it in the Hamiltonian.
It's not like-- the coulombic
interaction, of course,
keeps electrons away
from each other.
But the Pauli
Exclusion Principle
is essentially
something on top of that
that comes from
anti-symmeterizing the wave.
You don't see it
directly in the form--
as a term in the form
of the Hamiltonian.
And if you remember,
consequences of--
it's going to take forever--
the Pauli Exclusion
Principle is Hund's rule.
That if you remember
atomic d level,
say, for example, if you
add electrons to, say,
five d levels, you're going
to add them with parallel spin
first, because again, then
the Pauli Exclusion Principle
is satisfied.
And then you start filling them
with the anti-parallel levels.
So this is going to
carry over in atoms--
in solids-- I'm sorry.
Basically, if those five, say--
let's focus on d levels.
If they remain degenerate--
so they remain roughly
at the same level,
you're going to fill them
according to Hund's rule.
And that's what I've shown here.
So in solids,
these d levels will
split a little, which
is what I've shown here,
but they don't split a lot.
Then you're actually going to
fill them with parallel spin.
And so if that's the
case, you have a lot
of magnetic moment on your ion.
You have five
electron spins here.
You have no down spin, so you
have a strong magnetic moment.
And I'll show in a second
where that becomes important.
On the other hand,
let's say you're
in an environment that
splits off two of these,
but so much higher.
At some point, you won't
satisfy Hund's rule anymore,
because the energy
cost of-- let's say
after you put in these
three green electrons, now
you have to add two more.
You have five electrons.
To fill them with
parallel spin, you
would have to put them here.
But since those levers
are so much higher,
you basically want to pay
the exchange penalty--
they call it the
Hund's rule penalty--
to put them in a lower
orbit when you put them
in with anti-parallel.
So in some sense, whether you
get a lot of magnetic spin--
a lot of magnetic
moment left over
depends on how much your
orbital will split in the end.
But I'm going to
show you in the end
that it can actually have
significant consequences
on the physical properties
of your material.
So in your density
functional calculation,
you will carry a
magnetic moment locally
when the up density and the
down density are not the same.
And so I've sort of
already given away here
how this problem is dealt with
in density functional theory.
The interesting thing is that
if you think about it very hard,
you shouldn't have
to deal with spin
in density functional theory.
Somehow, it put me
back at my old picture.
In principle, remember
where we told you that--
Professor [? Mazari ?]
told you that the energy
and the potential is a
function of the charge density?
So the charge itself
should actually
also contain the information
about electron spin
and magnetic moment, even
though it doesn't explicitly
contain that.
But for a given
charge density, there
would probably be a certain
amount of spin polarization.
So it should all be in that
functional, but remember,
that's the functional
that we don't know.
And so in practice, that
doesn't work very well.
So what we do is
we really helped
density functional theory
along by treating the up
and the down density separately.
But again, you
should keep in mind
that in principle,
in the formalism
of density functional theory,
you wouldn't have to do that.
So if you do what's called,
say, the local spin density
approximation, which is the spin
polarized version of the Local
Density Approximation-- and
so goes under the name LSD--
Lucy in the Sky with
Diamonds, or LSDA.
And there's a version of that
for the GGA, which nobody--
often people will just
call it LDA or GGA,
but they will call it sometimes
spin polarized LDA or GGA.
What you do there is that
you have a separate density
for the up electrons
and a separate density
for the down electrons, and the
two will interact differently.
So the up/up will--
up will interact
differently with up,
with up, then up with down.
And that comes from the way
the exchange correlation
potentials are defined.
So I think Professor
[? Mazari ?] mentioned
restricted and unrestricted
to Hartree-Fock before
very briefly, and this is
essentially the same idea.
Sort of one quick tip
I want to give you
is that if you have spin
polarized materials,
it's often much more useful
to look at spin densities
than at charge densities.
One of the really cool things
about doing quantum mechanics
is that you can actually
look at the charge densities,
and look at the electrons,
which most people get
very excited about the first
time they do quantum mechanics.
It's kind of cool-- you can
look at where the electrons go.
Well, the first
thing you learn is
that you don't see much when
you look at charge densities.
You typically see
big blobs of charge,
and it's very hard to see
any fine structure of bonding
in blobs of charge density.
And I wanted to
show you an example.
Here's lithium cobalt oxide.
It's a transition metal oxide.
It's a layered material--
layers of oxygen
here-- the red things.
And then layers of cobalt,
and layers of lithium.
And if you plot the
charges in a plane--
this is actually a plane
in the plane of the figure.
If you look at
the charges-- this
is a picture of
the charge density.
You see big blobs, and you
see the oxygen layers here.
And where the
oxygens are 2 minus,
so remember that you're showing
only the valence electrons.
So these have a lot
of valence electrons,
and so you see a
lot of intensity.
Cobalt has somewhat less
valence electrons on it,
so you see less intensity here.
And lithium is ionized
to lithium plus,
so it has no valence
electrons on it,
so you see almost nothing here.
But in essence, this doesn't
give you a lot of detail.
If you actually take a
material like this, and rather
than plot the charges, you plot
the spin polarization density.
So let's say up minus
down, or down minus up.
So it's how much magnetic
moment there is locally.
You get much cleaner pictures.
This is the same picture.
It's a slightly
different material
with different ions in it.
It's with nickel
and manganese in it.
But here's the
oxygen. By the way,
I should have told you
red is the neutral color
in this picture, so it's 0.
So now you don't see
the oxygen at all,
and the reason is oxygen
doesn't have spin.
It's a filled shell.
Every time you have filled
shells, you don't have spin.
So looking at spin density
often allows you to filter out
certain ions, and you
really-- the transition metals
tend to have spin on them,
and you see that very clearly.
So it's often a trick that I
just wanted to share with you.
So I want to go in sort
of the last half hour--
is go through the kind
of numerical accuracy,
and then slowly try to connect
that to the physical accuracy
that you get in properties.
So if you want to use--
have initial methods in
density functional theory
to get to engineering
properties,
a lot of steps you have to
make, because in the end,
we calculate simple things.
We've got to get charge
densities, and band structures,
and energies.
And you'll talk
later to somebody,
and they want to know what's the
corrosion resistance of this.
And corrosion resistance
is not a quantum operator,
so you need to
take a lot of steps
to go from the simple, what I
would call primitive output,
to engineering properties.
But before you even
take that step,
you need to understand
the kind of accuracy--
how reliable your output is.
And so I collected
a lot of results.
And I was going to start
with the simple things--
the energies of the atoms.
So here's a collection, and it
looks like a bunch of numbers,
but there's a very
systematic trend in it.
So what I show for
a bunch of atoms--
and these all should have a
minus sign in front of them,
because if you sum up all the
electronic states in the atom,
they're obviously binding,
so they should be negative.
So there's always the
experimental line, at least
for most of them.
The LDA number, and then
the GGA with a fairly recent
implementation of the
exchange correlation function.
And so if you look
carefully at the numbers,
let's take one here-- let's
take carbon for example.
So experiment is 275688.
Oops, that wasn't good.
LDA, the binding energy
is somewhat weaker--
almost is an
electron volt weaker.
And GGA is slightly
closer to the experiment.
That's typically
what you'll see.
If you look at all
the other atoms,
you'll see a very
systematic trend.
In the LDA, in the atoms, the
electrons are not bound enough.
In the GGA, They are somewhat
closer to the experiment.
It gets more interesting
when you look at molecules,
because now you can talk about
a physical binding energy.
And so the one we look at
here is for very simple
diatomic molecules.
What's their binding energy?
So what's their energy
to pull them apart?
So if you think about
it, you have a molecule--
has an ab.
This is the vector between them.
You'll have sort of something
that looks like this.
And so we're looking at
what's that well depth here--
the binding energy.
If you look at hydrogen, H2,
you have the experimental number
here, the LDA number.
You see now that
the LDA number--
that the binding is too strong.
The H2 molecule is
bound too strongly.
It's not so bad.
It's only about 5% in hydrogen.
And the GGA, the binding
is too weak.
For reference, I've also put
uncorrected Hartree-Fock here.
Professor [? Mazari ?]
showed you essentially
what Hartree-Fock is,
which is essentially
having the Hartree term for
the self-consistent Coulomb
interaction from
the other electrons,
and the exact exchange with
no correlation effects.
This is an interesting one that
you will actually often use--
O2-- any time you look
at oxidation reactions,
for example.
Experiment-- oxygen is only
about minus 5.2 ev binding.
LDA binds by a
whopping 7 and 1/2.
So you're more than
two electron volts off.
GGA gets you a little
closer in this case.
Uncorrected Hartree-Fock
is off the charts.
And this is something
you'll generically see.
Uncorrected Hartree-Fock,
very few people
would actually
use that any more.
It's sort of for binding
energies way off the charts.
These things are important.
If you now-- let's
say you want to look
at an oxidation reaction.
So that means that
at some point,
you're going to calculate
the state of an oxide,
and compare the chemical
potential of the oxygen
there to that of oxygen gas.
So of course, you have a
big error in the oxygen gas.
The question is, how
much of that error
carries over to the solid?
If you make exactly the
same error in the solid,
then the reaction energy
is perfect, Because.
You're going to
subtract the two.
And a lot of
practical things you
do with density
functional theory
depend on error cancellation.
The thing is that you will
have more error cancellation
as the states that you subtract
are more physically similar.
But the problem
is, let's say, you
look at oxidation of a metal--
aluminum plus oxygen going
to aluminum oxide.
The oxygen in
aluminum oxide is very
different from the oxygen
in the O2 molecule,
so not all the
error will cancel.
Let's say it was so bad
that you kept 2 ev error.
So 2 ev error in the
molecule is one ev per oxygen
if you want to think
of it that way.
If you're not careful about
it, that's an enormous effect.
Think about it-- the
chemical potential which
relates directly
to the energy goes
like the logarithm of the
partial pressure of oxygen.
Remember that mu is
mu 0 plus rt log p?
So if now you invert
that, that means your--
if you wanted to calculate, say,
a partial pressure of oxygen
at which something oxidized,
your oxygen pressure
goes exponentially
with the energetics.
So if you have a 1 ev
error at room temperature,
your error in the
oxygen pressure
is the exponential
of one ev over kt,
which is off the charts.
So you have to be a little
careful with these kinds
of error calibrations.
Fortunately, we'll
see later when
we look at reaction between
solids, most of the error
tends to cancel, and we get
much, much better accuracy.
If all our reaction energies
were wrong by one ev,
we wouldn't be here.
We'd be out of business.
But you have to keep in
mind that you get less error
cancellation as the states
you're comparing are different.
The more they're different,
the less error cancellation.
That's sort of a rule of thumb.
And so going from
a gas to a solid
is a significant difference.
Often, what people
do is that if you
want to get practical
results, they'll
add a correction to this
which they fit at one point.
So these are the
small molecules.
Let's go to the solids.
Here I don't have
the binding energies,
but I have the
lattice parameters.
But you'll see
something that's very
consistent with the molecules.
If you look at the
lattice parameters,
you compare, say,
the experimental ones
versus the LDA ones.
What you'll see is that the
LDA ones almost always--
and I think always in
this case are smaller.
Actually, yeah, because
the difference is actually
negative.
The GGA results
are always bigger.
This is rather consistent
whatever material you do.
You will find almost always
that the LDA gives you
lattice parameters that are too
small by a factor of a percent,
sometimes, 2%.
And so people refer to that
as the over-binding of LDA.
LDA binds somewhat too strongly.
Remember you saw that in
the molecules as well.
Oxygen had a 7 ev
binding energy,
and it should only have
a 5 ev binding energy.
And so in solids, the
way that comes out
is that your equilibrium lattice
parameters are slightly too
small.
Actually, I'm not sure that
I know of a single result
where LDA gives a lattice
parameter that's too big.
I've seen that on some
occasions in papers,
but it's almost always an
indication that the people did
the calculation wrong.
Actually, an LDA
lattice parameter
that agrees with experiment
is usually wrong--
a wrong calculation.
GGA is much more unpredictable.
The ones that I've shown here
because they're simple metals
and semiconductors give
you a lattice parameter
that's too large.
In GGA, it's actually
also possible to get
a lattice parameter that's
too small, although it's rare.
Most of the time, you're
on the higher side,
but it's less predictable,
and that's sort of slightly
problematic with the GGA.
In LDA, a good
guess of the lattice
parameters-- you calculate
your lattice parameters,
and you know you're
on the low side.
You always know that the
real lattice parameter
is going to be bigger.
In GGA, it's slightly
more difficult to predict
on which side you are.
But in metals, you do tend
to be on the high side.
That actually has consequences
for other properties,
like the bulk modulus.
If you compare, say, the
experimental bulk modulus
to the LDA one, s you'll find
is that in almost all cases--
and I think in all cases
that I've shown-- well,
all cases except silicon--
the LDA bulk modulus
is too large,
so the material is
too stiff that means.
And that kind of goes together
with the over-binding.
Remember, the bonding
energy is too high,
the lattice parameter
is too small.
All that is kind of in
agreement with the material also
being too stiff.
As you compress the
material, it gets stiffer.
GGA, most of the time, if
you see from deviations,
has to be on the other side.
It tends to be too soft.
And bulk modulus
effects that will
transfer, for example, also
into vibrational frequencies.
In material, when you're
too hard, too stiff,
you'll have higher
vibrational frequency.
When you're too
soft, you'll have
lower vibrational frequencies.
Here's the same for oxides.
You're not exactly
learning a lot
new by looking at them, except
that in oxides, the errors just
tend to be slightly larger.
So here's the summary
for geometry prediction.
You almost always-- and I
would probably say always--
under-predict with LDA.
Less systematic errors with GGA.
For normal materials like
semiconductors and metals,
often, your errors are
confined to order 1% to 2%.
In transition metal oxides--
and if I have a chance,
I'll say a little
bit more about that
later because they have
electronic structures where
the LDA and GGA approximations
are particularly harsh on.
You tend to have
somewhat bigger errors.
But I may say a little more
about that if we get to it.
So I want to say something
about predicting structure,
and about the energy
scale that's required.
So this is often
something you want to do.
You want to know if I put my
energy in this arrangement,
is that lower in energy
than some other arrangement,
so I can kind of predict what
the most stable arrangement is.
So that could be [INAUDIBLE]
crystal structure,
but it's the same for if
you look, say, at a surface.
So I wanted to give you
a feeling for the scale
of energetic differences.
So for vanadium, I've listed
the atomic energy here
in [INAUDIBLE].
This is the energy
of all its electrons,
so not just the valence
electrons actually.
The energy for FCC
vanadium-- so remember,
the first line is the
atom, not in a solid.
The second line is the FCC iron,
and the third one is BCC iron.
So look at the differences.
First of all, if
you go from the atom
to the solid, your first four
digits don't even change.
And again, that's
a reflection of--
well, a lot of your deep
core states don't change.
But you would see
something similar even
with a pseudopotential
approximation where you only
deal with the valence electrons.
So the cohesive energy is only
0.03% of the total energy.
So if you're calculating--
the reason I'm saying this--
if you're calculating the
cohesive energy by first
calculating the total
energy of a solid,
and then calculating
atomic energy,
you'd better do these
things damn accurate,
because you're going
to subtract them,
and most of what you
subtract is the same.
So to get any significance
in your result,
you need to have high
numerical accuracy.
And that's not a big
problem with a lot of code,
but I want you to
keep that in mind.
But few people care about
the cohesive energy.
Let's say you want to know
whether vanadium is FCC or BCC.
So you could
calculate it as BCC.
Now the FCC/BCC
difference is only 0.001%
of the total energy.
And these are not
complicated structures.
So in many cases, we're going
to work with energy differences
that are fractions of--
so that are 10 to the
minus 6, 10 to the minus 7
times the total energy.
So it's sort of
telling you something
about how much numerical
accuracy you need.
If you want to look
at mixing energies--
let's say I mix vanadium
with something else--
platinum-- and you
want to know what's
the mixing enthalpy, because
that sets the whole temperature
scale for mixing, the whole
phase diagram topology.
That tends to be a fraction--
10 to minus 6, 10 to the
minus 7 of the total energy.
So my former advisor used to
compare this to-- let's say
you want to know the
weight of a captain that
sails a big supertanker.
It's like weighing the
tanker with the captain
and without the captain, and
looking at the difference,
and that's the weight
of the captain.
You're almost at a kind of
relative scale like that here.
So the [? cute ?]
thing really is
that all these
approximations we make
to density functional theory
are obviously not this accurate.
The total energy is not
accurate up to a fraction of 10
to the minus 6.
The only reason we're here and
we can get physical behavior
right is because
a lot of the error
the density functional
theory makes in LDA
and GGA is systematic.
And so a lot of it
cancels away when
you take energy differences.
When I do FCC and BCC vanadium,
yes, I may have an error of 10
to minus 4 in the
energy, but most of it
cancels away when I take
the energy difference.
And that's why we're lucky.
But you have to
keep that in mind,
because again, the less
cancellation you have,
the bigger your
error on the result.
So again, let me show you how
well or how badly it does.
So I did a very simple thing.
I looked at how well
does it predict, say,
the structure of the elements.
This is done in GGA, a standard
[? Trudel ?] potential method.
So this comes out-- you may
have to look at your hand
out because this is extremely
fuzzy on the screen.
In red, I did metals
that are experimentally
FCC, and green I did metals
that are experimentally BCC.
Now what I show you is
the calculated energy
difference between FCC
and BCC, and it's actually
the first line below every
element kind of like this.
And so when that's positive, the
BCC energy is higher than FCC,
so it's going to--
FCC is preferred over BCC.
If it's negative like here,
then BCC is preferred over FCC.
And so if you look--
so the color is
the experimental result,
the number is calculated.
So if you look at them
carefully, they're all correct.
It's negative when
we have green,
it's positive when we have red.
You can do a more
subtle comparison.
Look at the difference
between HCP--
Hexagonal Close Pack-- and FCC.
And the reason that
that's more subtle
is HCP FCC are much more alike.
They're all close pack.
It's just the
difference in stacking.
ab, ab, versus abc, abc.
And so again, you'll see
that they're all correct.
The red ones are the FCC ones.
They're the ones where that
first line is positive.
By the way, that number is
in kilojoules per mole here.
The yellow ones, that
number is negative.
So we get the structure of the
elements essentially correct.
There are notable exceptions.
In LDA, iron is wrong.
Iron is FCC in LDA, not BCC,
but in GGA, that's corrected.
And then there are the weirdos.
If you go deep down
in the periodic table,
especially f electron
metals have--
the f states are extremely
localized even in metals,
and so electron correlation
becomes very important here.
And I may say a little
more about that.
And so there you'll start
to see failures LDA and GGA.
An important one is plutonium.
Plutonium is kind of
important for obvious reasons,
especially if you work at
national labs these days.
And so people are building
more sophisticated methods
to deal with materials
such as plutonium.
Typically, when you work with
f electron metals, sometimes,
you'll get the answer
right, sometimes, you won't.
But you should be a
little more careful.
Let me skip this.
You can get the--
most of the time, you'll get the
structure of compounds right.
If you go to transition
metal oxides--
so I sort of went
from metallic elements
now to transition metal oxides--
most of the time, you also
get the structure right,
but things get more subtle.
In transition metal oxides,
the transition metal
has local d states.
And I showed you before they
often have significant spin
polarization, so the
first thing you need to do
is turn spin polarization
on, or you really
get the wrong answer.
But it often gets worse.
Remember that your spin is a
scalar, so it's up or down.
So now you have a
spatial degree of freedom
of how to organize
that spin on the ions.
If you have a bunch of
ions, you could put them
all with the same direction.
That's a ferromagnet,
or you could put them
with sort of
alternating direction
as a kind of a anti-ferromagnet.
And then there's many ways to
make them anti-ferromagnetic.
And unfortunately, in
transition metal oxide,
it often matters
because there's not only
a strong spin polarization
effect on the energy,
but there's a
fairly strong effect
of the interaction between
spins on different ions.
And I'm showing
you a result here.
This is a simple
crystal structure.
It's a structure of
lithium manganese oxide.
It's an ordered rock salt.
These are still very simple.
But the correct answer--
I'm showing the comparison
here between two structures
only labeled by their
symmetry, unfortunately.
One is C2/m, and one is pmmn.
There are similar structures,
but one is orthorhombic,
and one is monoclinic.
The correct answer is pmmn--
is the real crystal structure.
If you do a non-spin
polarized calculation--
so that's not even
allowing spin on the ions--
you get a whopping error.
I mean, C2/m is lower in energy
by 250 mill-electron volt
per formal unit.
That's very large.
In kilojoules, that'd be
25 kilojoules per mole.
It's a very large error.
If you turn on
spin polarization,
will make them ferromagnetic.
They're degenerate.
And if you make them
anti-ferromagnetic,
this one is the
lowest in energy.
Now here's a very common
mistake that people make.
If you take this material
at room temperature,
it's paramagnetic.
Some people say, well,
it's paramagnetic,
so I shouldn't have
any spin polarization--
there's no net moment.
That is so wrong, because
a paramagnet still
has a local moment.
The ions still have
a moment on them,
it's just randomly oriented.
So you still need to
represent that moment.
Because it turns out that's the
biggest effect on the energy
is the fact that you
have that local moment.
It's not necessarily
how they're arranged.
You can actually see that here.
How they're arranged makes
you go from this difference
to this difference.
But turning on the
local moment makes
you go from this difference
to that difference.
So never fall in that trap.
It's really only non-magnetic
materials or diamagnetic
materials for which you don't
really need spin polarization.
Now why is this
effect so important?
It's really because if
you spin polarize an ion,
you fill different orbitals.
I mean, I've shown that here
with a bunch of d orbitals.
And this is typically how
they split in most oxides.
Every time an ion
is octahedral--
five d orbitals tend to
split in pairs of 3, 2--
3 down, 2 up.
In some cases, 2 down, 3 up.
But let's say you
have to put four--
five electrons in there.
How many do I have?
I'm missing-- no,
four electrons.
If you put them--
that's called high spin.
So all parallel spin,
you put them like this.
If you put them low spin,
So here we have no moment.
So these two ions have
different chemical properties,
because the electrons
occupy different orbitals.
These are different d orbitals,
and so this orbital points
in a different direction,
for example, than this one.
So by spin
polarizing, you create
essentially a different ion.
It's not really an
issue of magnetism,
because magnetic effects tend
to be small in materials.
But it's the fact that
you create chemically
a different ion because
you fill different levels.
That's really why these
energy differences are so big.
I sort of want to end with
showing you some reaction
energies very quickly.
And I'm going to sort make
it systematically harder.
So here's a simple one.
A metal, lithium, BCC,
with another metal,
aluminum forming a
lithium-aluminum compound.
Here's the experimental reaction
energy, here's the LDA one.
10% off.
That's classic.
Metallic reaction
energies, you're somewhere
in the range 5% to 15%.
The one I show
here, copper-gold,
is a notable exception
where you're over 50% off.
But most of them,
it's much simpler.
So in metals, you tend to get
very good reaction energies.
I want to show you the
case where things go wrong.
Where your errors become
bigger is in redox reactions.
And I've shown sort of
here three different ones.
They're all related.
They're essentially a
reaction between an oxide,
or in this case, a
phosphate with a metal
to react the two together.
And if you look at
the reaction energies,
you're not considerably off.
GGA gives you 2.8 electronvolts
for this reaction.
Experiment is 3.5.
This one, which is very
similar, the error is 30%.
You get 3.3 electronvolts.
Experiment is 4.6.
Why is that?
Well, it has to do with the
lack of error cancellation.
If you look in
detail what happens
to the electronic structure
in these materials,
these are redox reactions.
So if you do the math on the
valences-- and believe me,
this ion here is 3 plus.
Phosphorus, 5 plus.
Oxygen is 2 minus, so
you can do the math.
Iron here is 2 plus,
and lithium is 1 plus.
So what has happened
in this reaction?
Well, you've taken essentially
an electron from lithium
in it's metallic state, and
put it on the iron 3 plus
to make iron 2 plus.
So essentially, you've
transferred an electron
from metallic lithium and
ionized lithium to the iron
to reduce it from
3 plus to 2 plus.
But think about
what's that doing?
That electron in lithium--
lithium is there in
the alkaline metals.
That's an s electron.
So that's a wide
delocalized orbital,
and I think it's metallic--
and you're transferring it to a
localized d state on the iron.
So that electron is
essentially being transferred
between extremely
different states,
and this is what's killing you.
Because you transfer between
such different states,
you start losing a lot of the
sort of cancellation of errors
that you need.
That's the functional theory.
And in particular,
the error here
comes from something
quite particular.
It comes from what we call
the self-interaction error.
So I'm trying to sort
make you understand
where these errors
come from so that when
you work on your application,
you get a bit of a feeling for.
If you remember how we
solve all these quantum
mechanical equations,
we reduce them
to one electronic
equations, where
you have the kinetic energy,
the nuclear potential.
And then this
effective potential
which, remember what
all goes in there.
The effective the
potential-- that's
the one that has the
exchange correlation in it,
but it also has the Hartree
field, so the coulombic field
from all the electrons.
Well, that field includes
the electron itself.
That's the sort of
oddity in essence.
When you calculate
the charge density,
that's the charge density
of all the electrons.
We then calculate
the potential coming
from the charge density, that's
the potential coming from all
the electrons.
But you operate that now
on a single electron.
So the electron is
feeling its own potential.
Part of the exchange
correlation term
corrects for that,
but not all of it.
And the problem is
that the correction
doesn't operate as well on
different forms of the charge
density.
In a metal, you have a small
self-interaction error.
And the reason is if you
look at a state in a metal,
sort of very delocalized.
So very spread out
charge density.
So if you want to think of
it, the part of the electron
here doesn't feel much of
the charge density coming--
of the potential coming from
that piece of the charge
density, because
they're very far away.
Whereas if you do a very
localized state, in some sense,
then the potential
from the electron
is very high where the
electron itself is sitting,
because it's all very close.
If you put an electron in
a delta function if you--
if you didn't have an
uncertainty principle,
and you calculate its
potential, it's basically
sitting on top of itself then.
You'd have an infinite
self-interaction.
So the more local the state
is, the more self-interaction
you have.
And the exchange
correlation functional
can't quite correct these
two in the same way.
And remember that the exchange
correlation correction comes
from homogeneous
charge densities,
so it tends to correct
the metallic state better
than the localized state.
And so this is why that redox
reaction I showed you had a big
error, because we were
transferring from a state that
was metallic-- the electron
went from the lithium state--
to the transition metal state.
And somehow, the
self-interaction error
doesn't cancel.
And you will see
things like that
whenever you transfer electrons
between quite different states,
so that's something
to keep in mind.
I think I'm running out of
time here, so yeah, let me
stop here.
So I'm summarizing
here because this is
the stuff I went over before.
In general, you do pretty well.
I think if I'd given this
summary 10 years ago,
I would have been even more
optimistic, because most people
worked on metals and
semiconductors which
tend to be fairly
delocalized state,
so LDA and GGA do quite well.
I think as we dig into
more complicated materials,
we have learned more about
the errors of LDA and GGA.
But on sort of
classic metals, you
do pretty well with lattice
constants, reaction energies,
and cohesive energies.
But now there is a series of
methods under development--
and if we have some time,
we might sort of just broach
them--
to deal better with
the correlation energy,
with the self-interaction
energy to solve
these problems of
both energetics
and also electronic structure--
things such as the band gap.
So I'll end here.
And remember, on
Tuesday, we have lab.
So you meet in the lab, and then
Thursday, we'll be back here.